marine le pen poursuit son tour de
france des fédérations départementales
une halte ce mercredi soir à versailles
pour soutenir les candidats aux
municipales avec désespoir dans les
yvelines
bien sûr c'est une fédération qui a
repris un très grand dynamisme qui ne
marchent très bien qui est une des
belles fédération d'île de france car
sur fond de crise de réforme des
retraites dose du chômage et
d'insécurité le front national est plus
que jamais sur de séduire les électeurs
l'ambiance a changé assurent les
représentants ce qui est extraordinaire
c'est que même des gens qu'on ne
sollicite pas même des gens qui ne sont
pas adhérents viennent nous voir et ça
franchement on doit beaucoup à marine
parce que elle a réussi quand même à ce
que des gens puissent comme ça venir
vernon sans avoir peur dans leur propre
commune d'afficher leurs couleurs dans
les yvelines dix sept têtes de liste
sont connus et à versailles le candidat
se voit déjà au second tour je pense que
le front national va rentrer en force au
conseil municipal de versailles de par
le fait que les thèses qui sont les
nôtres paraissent maintenant évidente
pour tout le monde aussi bien pour les
gens de droite pour les gens de gauche
un front national qui fait moins peur il
y a trois jours en picardie une brèche
s'est ouverte avec une alliance locale
pour les municipales entre le fn et
l'ump et marine le pen laisse la porte
entrebâillée
nous ne pouvons pas faire un accord
national avec l'ump donc il y aura
peut-être des liste d'intérêt communal
qui pourront voir sur des gens qui
viennent de l'ump des gens du front
national il y en aura quelques unes
c'est possible en france le fn a déjà
rassemblé 450 candidats sur le secteur
de saint quentin en yvelines et philippe
jury n'a pas caché la probabilité d'une
liste frontiste à montigny le bretonneux